I was four in 1993 in the northern part
of North Korea in a town called Hazen
which is on the border with China
I had loving parents and one older
sister ah before I was even ten years
old my father was sent to labor camp for
engaging in illegal trading now delivery
trading he was selling clocks sugar rice
and later copper to feed us in 2007 my
sister and I decided to escape she was
16 years old and I was 13 years old
oh I need you to understand what the
word escape means in the context of
North Korea we are starving and hunger
means death in North Korea so it was the
only option for us I didn't even
understand the concept of escape but I
crystallized from China and night and I
wondered if I goes where the light is I
might be able to find a bowl of rice
it's not like we had a grand plan or
maps we did not know anything about
what's going to happen
imagine your apartment building caught
fire
I mean what would you do would you stay
there to be burned or would you jump off
out of the window and see what happens
that's what we did we jumped
the house inside the fire North Korea is
unimaginable it's very hard for me when
people ask me what it feels like to live
there to be honest I tell you you can't
even imagine it the words in any
language can't describe because it's a
totally different planet as you cannot
imagine your life on Mars Rana for
example the word love has only one
meaning love for the Dear Leader there's
no concept of romantic love in North
Korea and if you don't know the words
that means you don't understand the
concept and therefore you don't even
realize that concept is even a
possibility let me give you another
example growing up in North Korea we
truly believe that our dear leader is on
Almighty God who can even with my
thoughts I was even afraid to think in
North Korea and we are told that he is
starving for us and he's working
tirelessly for us and my heart just
broke for him when I escaped to South
Korea people told me that he was
actually a dictator he had a cars many
many resorts and he had ultra luxurious
life and and I remember looking at a
picture of him realizing for the first
time that he is the largest guy in the
picture
and hear me finally I realized he wasn't
starving but I was never able to see
that before until someone told me that
he was fat
really someone had to teaching me that
he was fat if you have never practiced
critical thinking then you simply see
what you're told to see biggest
questioner so people ask me is that why
there is no revolution inside North
Korea are we done why there is no
revolution for 70 years of this
oppression and I say if you don't know
your slave if you don't know your
isolated or oppressed how do you fight
to be free I mean if you know your your
isolated that means you are not isolated
not knowing is a true definition of
isolation and that's why I never knew I
was isolated when I was in North Korea I
literally thought I was in the center of
universe so here is my idea worth
spreading a lot of people think humans
inherently know what is right and wrong
the difference between justice and
injustice what we deserve and we don't
deserve I tell them yes
[Applause]
everything everything must be thought
including compassion oh if I see someone
time on the street right now I will do
anything to save that person but when I
was in North Korea and so people dying
and death on the streets after nothing
not because I'm psychopath because I
never learned concept of compassion only
ifer compassion apathy and sympathy in
my heart after I learned the word
compassion and the concept and I fear
them now oh now I live in the United
States as a free person
and recently the literal frequency our
president Trump met with my former God
and he decided human rights is not
important enough to include and he is
one of agendas and he did not talk about
it and it scares me we live in a world
right now where a dictator can be
praised for executing his uncle for
killing his a half-brother cling
thousands of North Koreans and that was
worthy of praise and also in making me
think perhaps we all need to be taught
something new about freedom now
freedom is fragile I don't want to harm
you but it is it only took three
generations to make North Korea in
George Orwell's 1984 it's only three
generations if we don't fight for human
rights for the people who are oppressed
right now who doesn't have voice as free
people here who will fight for us when
we are not free Russians
animals I don't know I think it's
wonderful that we care about climate
change and the moral rights gender
equality all of these things the fact
that we care about animals rights that
means that's how beautiful our heart is
they read care about someone who cannot
speak for themselves and North Korea
Serena cannot speak for themselves they
don't have internet in 21st century we
don't have electricity and it is the
darkest place on earth right now now I
want to say something to my cell on our
screens
who are living in the darkness they
might not believe this but I want to
tell them the alternative life is
possible
Fifi Oh
from my experience literally thing is
possible
I was people I was sold as a slave but
now I'm here and that is why I believe
in me occurs the one thing that I
learned from history is that nothing is
forever in this world and that is why we
have every reason to be hopeful thank
you
[Applause]